[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of the wheel of time episode four
the dragon reborn this was directed by
wayne yip and written by dave hill so we
got three story lines going on in this
episode and i'm going to break my review
down into those three story lines so
we'll cover the main story first then
get to a gwain and then we'll get to
matt and rand later but with the main
story it actually opens the episode with
this sequence that's in the past with
this character of logan now with the
sequence of him taking over the city in
this castle and getting basically this
king and his army on his side and to
follow him you know i really like the
aerial shots here in this sequence but
it was strange that some of the knights
costumes look like they're from party
city and you wish maybe that they could
have done something with the lighting
here to kind of mask that if they're
gonna go with super expensive looking
costumes that a night would wear uh so
that's some of the frustrating decisions
that you'll see in the show throughout
where there's so much money put into it
but you wanna see more of that shown on
the screen and it hasn't been too much
but the cool thing about this whole
logane story is that these voices he's
hearing he thinks it's dragons from the
past but it's really just this madness
that has overcome him and i really like
how they kind of warmed us up to that
and that we didn't know if he was a
dragon reborn or not if he's just a
poser and that we get the payoff already
by the end of this episode you know
what's interesting as this episode went
on this might not be a very popular
opinion but one of my favorite
characters so far is now leandron who
wears the red i was agreeing with a lot
she was saying in this episode i don't
know that says about me but it seems
like she was right from the start you
know like screw all the traditional
rules here and being honorable let's
just take care of this guy and channel
him because she ends up doing it anyway
by the end of this episode and it
probably would have prevented karini
from dying who karini they did with her
story she's being the honorable one and
she's one who pays the price in the end
but i do like with all these characters
that it seems like there was a good pace
to giving us all this information about
the different colors it was cool seeing
them in the different colors but also
the tents in their camp with the
different colors and them throwing in
lines explaining what each color means
for the ice to die and what it means for
what you're expected to do they also did
well was having kirini's water here
talking mad [ __ ] here about lan and
moraine and making us wonder as the
audience who can we trust because they
were kind of painted in a really good
light the first two episodes and now
you're questioning you're questioning in
this whole show who you can trust and i
really like that and what they did well
about the main story in this episode is
the knave was taking the place of the
audience that we're learning all this
information through her character so it
not only gives us that kind of character
we can attach to to kind of get through
all this and get an understanding of
this world but it also brings us closer
to that character of the knave as well
we also see that in ave misread lan here
that she sees he is an honorable person
in the sense that he promises that he'll
help her find her friends like he said
so she had misjudged him but what's
interesting too is that she says she
misjudged him to be just a lap dog but
he says back well i thought you exactly
were who you are and that was
interesting because it was cut off so
you're wondering if he already got the
idea that she might be the dragon reborn
and have these other powers that are
revealed at the end and they have some
important character stuff that works
well where it doesn't feel forced in it
naturally comes in and we're learning
through this water that the bond between
water and isodi is stronger than
husbands and wives or the relationship
between parents and their children so
they do it smoothly i get it it's not
confusing and it's shown then
with lan and moraine here and they have
a nice scene in the tent and she's like
your losses are mine and my losses are
yours so again it's building a strong
relationship that we can attach to makes
them likable but again slowly trickles
in feelings of can we trust them as well
now this army that logan got in the past
sequence shows up now at the camp this
one [ __ ] it's the fan i really love the
moment when alana who we meet who wears
the green that she stops these arrows
and shoots it at the army i thought that
was really cool however what is strange
is when they're battling in the woods i
don't know if it was just the lighting
and the overuse of handheld camera but
it did feel like a student film you're
watching on youtube about the wheel of
time so
i don't know why it looks that way 100
but it's disappointing nonetheless
and what disappoints me is you'll see
even in the moments here we're gonna get
that are big with logan and the cgi not
being so great and we know such a huge
budget for amazon what worries me is no
matter what the budget is this is also
sony pictures television so whenever i
see sony i worry especially their cgi
history you could see it in the venom
movie and spiderman movies it's not
great no matter how much money you give
sony and they put into a project they
just don't have a great reputation of
giving quality content all the time and
high quality so this does not surprise
me when you see in the credits that sony
and amazon did this as a joint project i
really like this line maureen says to
logan where she's like the wheel doesn't
want anything it's people who want and
it's a nice way to just show the
difference in those two characters to
give us a better idea of the wheel and
what people believe about the wheel and
it's a nice moment to throw it in there
when moraine's calling out logan for
being basically a poser and not really
being the dragon reborn but i did like
the moment here where the warder attacks
logan and then literally the axe fires
back and almost hits the nev and if i'm
butchering any of these names just tell
me in the comments i can take it please
bear with me i didn't read the book so
i'm trying here with all these names and
learning them there's so many names
ending with ain't like moraine logan
eguin it's like i hope that means
something it just made me think of
rogaine as a bald man um but you know
that was a really cool scene and i think
that it's awesome at the end of the day
we got to see leandron channel and then
take out this madness from the game but
the big reveal here is nanive is able to
channel and she also heals in that
process lorraine and lam so i thought
that was a really cool reveal and it was
a good way to end the episode so i
thought the main story here was really
really strong and pretty well done still
having some same issues where some of
the costumes look cheap some of the
special effects aren't great so
hopefully
i mean i think you can only hope maybe
season two which has already been
approved they
actually use the budget correctly
because you're not going to see it this
season for sure we're already kind of
getting a feel for what we're getting
now let's switch over to aguain and
parents story here where they're with
these wagon people and these are people
that fall away of the leaf they're
against violence and i like this line
when they're explaining you know they
would run if they can if not they just
endure it and this lady with the stick
is kind of giving us all this
information she's like nothing's is
everlast the wheel returns all which i
thought was really interesting and cool
for someone who hasn't read the books
kind of gets me interested in it's like
a reincarnation type vibe here a little
bit of a hippie vibe too and you see
that important line she says the parent
has your life been better or worse since
you picked up the axe so to someone
who's been a violent person who's
accidentally killed his wife with an axe
this is how he's going to change as a
character and these are exactly the type
of people you'd want him with the
complete opposite to make his character
have growth and change i like to the
scenes we get with the lady with the
stick and perrin because she has a nice
little justification backstory for why
she believes the way she does it's not
just random you know that she lost her
daughter but this great line she has
what greater revenge against violence
and peace what greater revenge against
death is life i'm sure that's straight
from the books that's some great writing
people confirm that book readers i love
to hear that the wheel will turn out my
daughter's soul again i can do what i
can to forge a better world for her then
that's really cool stuff to me and
that's exciting fantasy stuff to me that
seems fresh and i'm excited to see what
that really means that's something as a
viewer got me very intrigued and got me
to sit up a bit nothing with the guys
catching me yet but i feel like that
will come they're kind of slowly putting
her in the background with little drips
of her so we'll see but the stuff with
the song and her with this guy i wasn't
there yet with her i'm not that
interested that was the only part of the
episode maybe i was a little bored now
what i also really liked if we switched
the other storyline here is with rand
matt and tom and rand's thinking on his
toes too to get the audience to think on
their toes because ran's another
character that we're kind of living
through as the audience and he suggests
possibly to matt that tom might have
killed that bartender to gain their
trust so we're not totally sure about
him and that a fade is coming for them
and you know i thought the fade was the
dark one that confused me last but all
the comments have made it clear thank
you that fade the voldemort character
that's what it's called uh but it's such
an awesome character i think that's one
of the things that looks great you know
cg wise and you see the difference
between a character like tom and rand
and what makes randa good guys he wants
to ask to go into this barn and tom just
wants to sneak into it again makes you
not really trust this guy tom in general
but you see quickly and i like how they
do it so subtle that tom sees matt go
for his blade when this man who owns the
barn confronts them and that will lead
nicely into matt puking this black at
night and it reminds me almost we want
to go fantasy here of like frodo getting
possessed by the ring in a sense and
this little girl gives him bread which i
thought was a nice moment and this
obviously hits him because he misses his
sisters who are young like her she gives
him her doll i don't think it was
totally earned the moment when they
leave and the dolls on the ground he
forgot it i don't think there's enough
time given to that to really be like oh
you know like it was just okay i get
what they were going for but just i
don't think there was enough weight to
it with the girl yet it was a quick
scene with her and matt maybe too quick
but this was some interesting stuff too
where tom brings up to rand about his
nephew owen who reminds him of what
matt's going through and that he snapped
and eventually threw a rock without
using his hands so he's like the dark
one corrupted the one power so men
couldn't use without going mad so this
directly relates to
little gain in the rest of the episode
so i like that that kind of all ties in
together and it also ties in now he
explains that isa gentled him and the
problem with that is when you cut off
from the power that you had there's not
life to you anymore and that he slit his
own throat so that's why they keep matt
away from those women so that's really
interesting and a completely different
perspective than someone like leandren
and then we get this really cool
sequence when rand's having a nightmare
and it's like parent i think he's
chopping his wife in that nightmare if
someone can confirm that and the dark
ones grabbing i think it's the dark one
is grabbing iguain maybe it's not the
dark one this you know character with
the fire in its eyes but let me know uh
if i'm on to the right track here
without spoiling the book if that's
possible uh but wakes up to matt gone
rand and the family slaughter and at
first i thought this was matt but
clearly it's not because we see there's
a fade there and that the blade led him
to this fade and i thought this was a
really well done scene it was again a
little too short for my taste because i
was just getting into this fight that
was about to happen i was more
interested in this fight than the big
battle on the other side which was
interesting because it just looks so
cool and look i didn't even know until
recently that the actor of matt barney
harris unfortunately has been recast for
season two there's no clarification i've
found on the internet of why this
happened there could be a bunch of
reasons could be scheduling conflict
could be something happening on set who
knows if anyone has heard any updates
please let me know why they did that
because unfortunately i think he's one
of the better actors in the show i think
he's done great i think he's brought me
into the character of matt perfectly and
sells everything and it's hard to sell
someone who's getting possessed too so i
thought he was to stand out here in this
episode so it sucks that he's not gonna
be here for season two but overall i
think this is right up there with
episode two and one of my favorite
episodes this season with good pacing
everything serves a purpose to move the
plot forward obviously the show has its
issues like i said with you know
costumes and cg but i haven't read the
book so i still have the suspense i
don't know exactly what's going on
that's what's making me excited but i'm
intrigued by all of it and this was the
most intrigued i've been yet so i'm
actually giving this one an 8.8 i
thought it was really strong and really
is getting me excited now in the groove
of the show and for what's to come and i
thought they did a good job with
blending and exposition but keeping it
interesting with action and i still
think everyone here is a really good
actor i don't think there's any bad
performances i don't get people saying
there's bad acting here that is not the
case i think they just want it to be bad
acting uh and there's other reasons why
they don't like you know certain
characters because it's not exactly
their vision from the book look i
haven't read the books i'm gonna go a
little rant here but it looks like a lot
of book fans hate the show and that's
totally justified like that's your
opinion i'm reviewing this like someone
who's watching this who clearly hasn't
read the books and i'm watching as a tv
show so i am enjoying it from that
perspective i'm gonna tell you how i
feel when i watch it but maybe if i read
the books i would hate it too i don't
know i have no idea so it's really
interesting and fascinating you're gonna
get so many different opinions on a show
like this from people read it who
haven't so let me know if you're in
either party and like i always say no
book spoilers please um let's keep that
somewhere else you can talk about the
books but stuff we've already seen but
please don't spoil let let us enjoy this
for the first time but yeah i love book
readers to explain some stuff maybe i
got wrong or kind of clarify some stuff
even cool someone can clarify the color
stuff i think people love to read that i
appreciate all the stuff you guys bring
to this too we're doing this together
this review i consider as a team so
thank you book readers but uh i'm hoping
i'm doing this some justice and uh yeah
but yeah let me know what you thought of
the episode down below i read every
comment try to respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of the
wheel of time i'll be doing every single
episode so you're not gonna want to miss
that and please follow me at stevenshow
on twitter instagram and tick tock for
more of me
and i'll see you next time